with uncharted one and two recapped it's
now time to get stuck into the most
recent game in the series uncharted 3
drake's Deception if you haven't played
it this video is riddled with spoilers
just like part 1 and 2 the story kicks
off with Nate and Sully meeting a man
named Talbot in London who wants to
purchase Nate's ring which belong to his
ancestor Francis Drake for a client
things don't go to plan when the to find
out Talbot has brought fake banknotes
they fight off Talbots goons semi
successfully and have a run-in with a
nasty aforementioned client Katherine
Marlowe who steals Drake's ring right
before Sully and Nate up both shot since
those two don't appear to be going
anywhere anytime soon
the story shoots us back 20 years to
join a 15 year old Nathan Drake who's
looking for Frances ring in a Colombian
Museum this is where baby Nate meets
Sully for the first time who was working
with Marlowe to retrieve Drake's ring
but ultimately decides to rescue Nate
from the agents instead and takes him on
as a protege back in the present day we
find out that the shooting was faked by
Nate and Sally's friend charlie cutter
and that the entire plan was devised to
flush out Malo
natan Sully get more help from another
old friend Chloe who traces Marlowe's
car to an underground library where they
discovered that Francis Drake was
commissioned by Queen Elizabeth the
first and her adviser John Dee to search
for the lost city of uber Nate does his
investigation thing and the sauce is out
that clues to the city's location can be
found in crusader crypts in a French
chateau and a Syrian Citadel Nate and
Sully kick on to France where they find
half an amulet inside a crypt and have
been ambushed by Talbot who takes it
then despised things up a bit
flesh-eating spiders no on one of
Talbot's men our heroes escape and the
Chateau is set on fire which is there on
the appropriate course of action when
you see spiders Nate and Sully head off
to Syria and meet up with Chloe and
cutter who've learned Marlowe is the
head of secret order the same order
Francis Drake was in they find the other
half of the amulet and a sign that they
should head to
Emin unfortunately an encounter with
molly's men results in cutter breaking
his leg so he and Chloe are unable to
come along and here we are the part of
the recap where we find out just how
nate and Elena's love life is doing
turns out not super well as these two
have not only been married between games
but also separated and presently
estranged nonetheless Elena is
eventually persuaded into helping them
locate an underground tomb where they
discover the lost city of a bar is in
the Rue Baha'i desert unfortunately they
also discover more shitty little flesh
hungry spiders now this is where [ __ ]
really hits the fan nate is shot with a
hallucinogenic Dart and freaks out at
Elena and Sully before running off on
his own he's then nabbed by Malo who
says she has a bunch of documents about
Nate's childhood he tries to get away
but is nabbed again this time by
Ramsay's a pirate working for Malo
ramses interrogate Sneyd for info and
claims to have captured Sully Nate
escapes his captors yet again and
searches for Sully on the pirate stolen
cruise ship discovering Sully isn't
aboard Nate detonates a grenade blowing
the ship open and shoots Ramses who then
shoots out the ship's glass ceiling
flooding the vessel and killing himself
in an effort to take out Nate but Nate
manages to escape because that's what
Nate does escape stuff like his captors
and death-defying situations and his
marriage Nate washes ashore and reunites
with Elena she tells him that the
baddies do have Sully and he's being
forced to lead Marlow to a bar Nate
attempts to rescue him by sneaking onto
a cargo plane which works great right up
until the plane is torn apart by an
explosion and Nate plummets to the
desert below narrowly deploying a cargo
parachute after a very long desert
wander Nate runs into MA
lose men but a man named Salim and his
tribe ride in to save the day
Nate's new best friend Salim tells him
who Bob was doomed by King Solomon
thousands of years ago when he
imprisoned evil jinn within a frost
vessel and threw it into the sea
in short jamie's in a bottle evil genies
in a bottle Natan Salim take out Marlo's
convoy and Saif Sully
but sadly neat and Sally lose Salim in a
sandstorm just as they reach the gates
to a bar once inside the city nate
drinks from a mysterious water fountain
which seems like a terrible idea they
witness a solar eclipse and then Talbot
and mallow arrive and shoot Sally
dead Nate chases them down and fends off
Marlowe's men who have been seemingly
possessed by said evil genies Nate trips
out hard and has twisted visions of his
childhood before finally sobering up and
finding Sully alive and well Sully
explains that ubers water supply is
tainted from when the evil genie bottle
was thrown into the water and now it
causes hallucinations
it seems Francis Drake opted for the
smart route and abandoned his quest for
the genie vessel upon discovering this
our heroes find the villain of the story
Marlow winching the vessel up from the
water
Talbot nearly kills Sully by kicking him
into the water
but Nate dives in and destroys the winch
accidentally exploding the central
cistern causing the city to begin
collapsing mallow gets trapped in a
sinkhole and even though she sucks
Nate tries to save her but he ultimately
fails and nobody really Minds although
she does drag Drake's ring down with her
Talbert and Nate have a final faceoff
that ends with Sully and Nate shooting
him until he also falls into the
sinkhole
Kaleem then rides in in the nick of time
to save Sully and Nate back at the
airport Sully tells Nate he's the son he
never had and gives Nate back his
wedding ring which he'd kept safe after
Nate and Elena separated Elaina and Nate
decide to make a go of it again still
not questioning whether they're at all
right for each other and a three fly off
in Sully's sweet new plane if you've
caught all three of these videos you're
officially ready for Uncharted 4 and
count me incredibly surprised if Elena
and native kept things stable between
uncharted 3 & 4 let me know what your
favorite Uncharted moment has been in
that comment box and
thanks for watching
you